♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
JUST IN CASE YOU WERE
WONDERING WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT WAS SERIOUS ABOUT
THE BORDER CRISIS.
LAST NIGHT HE DELIVERED A
DECISIVE ANSWER.
A SURPRISE MOVE THE WHITE
HOUSE ANNOUNCED THAT UNLESS
MEXICO HALTS THE FLOW OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS INTO THE
UNITED STATES, THE U.S.
WILL, STARTING ON JUNE 10TH,
IMPOSE A 5% TARIFF ON ALL
IMPORTS FROM THAT COUNTRY.
IF THE SITUATION DOESN'T
IMPROVE GOING FORWARD, THE
TARIFF WILL RISE BY 5% A
MONTH EVERY MONTH.
BY OCTOBER THERE WILL BE 25%
TARIFF ON ALL GOODS COMING
FROM MEXICO FROM AFTER AVOCADOST
FROM MEXICO FROM AFTER AVOCADOSO
AUTOMOBILES.
LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT WHAT
THAT WOULD MEAN.
THE U.S. IMPORTS
$372 BILLION WORTH OF GOOD
FROM MEXICO EVERY YEAR.
THE PRICES ON ALL OF THOSE
GOODS WOULD LIKELY GO UP,
CONSUMERS WOULD FEEL THAT SO
WOULD BUSINESSES.
CRITICS CLAIM THAT THE
TARIFFS WOULD SLOW THE U.S.
ECONOMY AND THEY ARE LIKELY
RIGHT.
OVER TIME THEY PROBABLY
WOULD.
BUT WE OUGHT TO IMPOSE THEM
ANYWAY.
NOT EVERY GOVERNMENT POLICY
IS A PURE ECONOMIC
CALCULATION.
THE UNITED STATES IS
ATTACKED BY AS WHO TILL
FOREIGN POWER.
IT MUST STRIKE BACK AND MAKE
NO MISTAKE MEXICO IS A
HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER.
FOR DECADES THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT HAS SENT ITS POOR
NORTH TO OUR COUNTRY.
THIS HAS ALLOW THAT
COUNTRY'S CRIMINAL OLIGARCHY
TO MAINTAIN POWER AND GET
EVEN RICHER BUT AT GREAT
EXPENSE TO US.
IN THE UNITED STATES DAMAGED
OUR COMMUNITIES, RUINED OUR
SCHOOLS, BURDENED OUR HECK
SYSTEM AND FRACTURED OUR
NATIONAL UNITY.
IT HAS SUPPRESSED WAGES FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
IT HAS BEEN A SLOW MOTION
ATTACK ON THIS COUNTRY AND
ITS EFFECTS HAVE BEEN
DEFICIT STATING.
THERE IS NOT A LOT OF
REDEBATE YOU WILL ADMIT IT.
BUT OUR LEADERS ARE NOT
HONEST.
IN THE HOURS AFTER THE
PRESIDENT'S ANNOUNCEMENT,
THEY INSTINCTIVELY SIDED
WITH MEXICO.
>> WELL, TARIFF MAN IS BACK.
THE PRESIDENT IS THREATENING
A NEW COUNTRY WITH NEW
TARIFFS THIS TIME MEXICO.
>> IT SOUNDS VERY STRONG BUT
WHOM WILL IT SQUEEZE?
US?
OR MEXICO?
>> NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT.
THE U.S. CONSUMERS WILL BEAR
THE BRUNT OF THESE TARIFFS.
>> WHETHER IT'S A
NEGOTIATING TACTIC OR AN
ATTEMPT TO DISTRACT, IT
STILL SURPRISED EVERYONE.
>> NOTHING SHORT OF A
POLITICAL STUNT.
>> SO, YOU KNOW, I DON'T
KNOW, MAYBE IT WAS CHANGING
THE SUBJECT FROM MUELLER.
I CAN'T FIGURE IT OUT.
>> JOHN KASICH CAN'T FIGURE
IT OUT.
IT'S TOO COMPLICATED FOR
HIM.
THE LINE OF THE WEEK, THE
AWARD FOR THE MOST
DISINGENUOUS RESPONSE FROM A
WORLD LEADER HAS TO GO TO
THE MEXICAN PRESIDENT LOPEZ
EL
OBRADOR:  SOCIAL PROBLEMS
ARE NOT RESOLVED WITH TAXES
OR CO-ERIVE MEASURES --
COERCIVE SOLUTION.
HE WENT ON TO LECTURE U.S.
PRESIDENT BECAUSE OF
AMERICA'S NATIONAL VALUES
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT OF
MEXICO IS JUST THAT ARROGANT
AND PRESUMPTUOUS TO DO THAT
GOAT THE STATUE OF LIBERTY
IS NOT AN EMPTY SYMBOL.
WELL, MEXICO'S CORRUPT
RULING CLASS BELIEVES IT IS
AMERICA'S DUTY TO ABSORB
THEIR COUNTRY'S PROBLEMS
FOREVER.